[Applaudissements]
la parole aucun stéphane guillon
politique françois bayrou lance son
slogan de campagne
un autre chemin après la rupture
tranquille de sarkozy jouer à notre
concours le slogan le plus con un détour
en ligne droite un raccourci plus longue
le gagnant passe une journée xt vie
pour se détendre le week-end dernier
sarkozy était à eurodisney une aubaine
pour les enfants avoir un des nains de
blanche neige en chair et en os
françois bayrou aussi voulait y aller
mais comme on a pris un autre chemin
laisser retrouver de l'autre côté au
péage de saint-arnoult
au gymnase japy à paris ségolène royal
s'adresser aux femmes voilées mutilé
excisées viol est écrasée alors on peut
concourir dans plusieurs catégories
comme carlier par exemple étaient voilés
le jour de son mariage puis écrasé lors
de sa nuit de noces à des
politiques internationales avec la mort
prochaine d'augusto pinochet c'est tout
un savoir faire qui va disparaître tyran
sanguinaire un métier qui n'intéresse
plus nos jeunes jadis on se transmettait
la charge grand père était un [ __ ]
père était un [ __ ] je suis un [ __ ]
le bar beat polpot milosevic bientôt
saddam hussein plus aucun client pour
maître vergès
une idée de reconversion
avocat à la reine de france un poste
très con mais moins exposés
russie pour relancer la natalité un
concours de beauté de femmes enceintes
également le concours du plus beau chaud
pour relancer les ventes de polonium
bons plans samedi dernier je vous
parlais de chirurgie esthétique discount
30% moins cher à l'étranger et bien
encore mieux cette semaine au maroc on
pouvait s'offrir une chirurgie faciale
complète pour le prix d'un billet
d'autocar
attendez c'est pire après
tu les jambes ou
technologie le gouvernement veut
généraliser la télévision sur téléphone
mobile génial pouvoir regarder la télé
dans la rue tu sors d'un peep show tu
mets la méthode cauet tu restes dans la
même ambiance
pipoles chimène badi rêve d'amérique
est ce que l'amérique rêve de chimène
badi
george clooney a perdu son cochon
l'animal aveugle souffrait d'arthrite
alors nous aussi on en a ici il a perdu
sa prostate il est borgne
mais
malheureusement il tient le coup
pascal sevran a déclaré au journal nice
matin qu'il fallait stériliser la moitié
de la planète dommage que sa maman n'est
pas eu cette idée en 44
on termine quand le sport déclarations
de jean-françois lamour aux jeux
paralympiques les primes des athlètes
handicapés seront équivalentes à celles
des athlètes valides c'est normal le
spectacle et hop le basket pour main
avec un système de trampoline pour
accéder au panier si l'athlète rentrer
avec le ballon le point compte double le
water-polo pour paraplégiques toutes les
minutes les fauteuils sont hissés à la
surface en cas de fautes on replonge
l'athlète le tir à l'arc pour
non-voyants exceptionnellement l'accès
aux tribunes et gratuit
allez semaine prochaine hier vers 10
heures et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu